[Music]
in less than half a year james gunn's
newest superhero movie the suicide squad
will be out and we now have a whole lot
of new
info on the dc blockbuster to share with
you according to the official synopsis
part of the action takes place in
bellrep
the prison with the highest mortality
rate in the u.s
to escape from it all many super
villains joined task force x
including bloodsport peacemaker captain
boomerang ratcatcher
kingshark blackheart javelin and of
course
harley quinn they must then not only
make their way through rough terrain and
a secluded island but they must defeat
the anime gorilla forces as well
in the merciless fight for survival the
rule any mistake is lethal
applies and as gun has already
emphasized many times in the past
he does not hesitate to give his
characters early on-screen deaths
on twitter the director is also heating
up the anticipation for margo roby's
harley quinn as the 54 year old is
looking forward to her entrance the most
in a few days the shooting will be done
and there will be more news to be
excited about
soon since there will be some unexpected
appearances and gun assured us that the
long-awaited trailer will be released
before may
the us release date of this suicide
squad will then be on august 6
2021 shortly before the end of
production on mission impossible 7
deadline reports that the long-term
planned project of shooting part 7 and
part 8 simultaneously has now been
scrapped one reason for this is tom
cruise's long announced promo tour for
the follow-up to the cult film top gun
which is scheduled for u.s release on
july 2nd this year
the plan is to continue with mission
impossible aid shortly after the release
of top gun maverick
further causes the more difficult
filming conditions due to the pandemic
as was already seen in the filming of
mission impossible 7 which was
repeatedly interrupted
behind the scenes however nothing
changes so christopher mcquarrie will of
course also take over the direction of
mission impossible 8
the release dates of the two movies have
not changed as of
yet part 7 will still be released on
november 19th
2021 while the sequel will be released
one year later on november 4th
2022 well over a decade ago producer and
director rm pellet released the first
part of the now world famous horror
series
paranormal activity what made it special
his surprise had grossed a staggering
193 million us dollars on a mere 15 000
budget after several sequels and a
spin-off it's now time for a new one and
media reports confirmed that the entire
paranormal activity brand is to be
renewed for
theaters rumors have been circulating
for some time that the new part was
imminent but the fact that the entire
franchise is being revamped and started
from scratch
was not apparent until now concrete
details about the content are still
scarce at this point but it's more than
likely that we'll see a return of the
all tried and true
found footage material underwater
director will eubank is expected to be
in the director's chair while happy
death day director christophe lennon
will be in charge of the film script
behind the scenes paranormal activity
will get support from horror producer
jason blum
alongside the creator of the first part
orrin pillai the us release of
paranormal activity is so far scheduled
for march 4th
2022 originally a third film about the
popular children's book character
paddington bear was supposed to be
released at the end of last year as so
often happens behind the scenes however
they could not bring themselves to begin
production and so the project was put on
hold for an
indefinite period of time as variety now
reports though
those responsible studio canal have
finally given the green light as actor
hugh boneville also confirmed in a radio
interview
paul king the screenwriter and director
of the two predecessors announced on
this occasion
that he would no longer be directly
involved on the set and would instead
take on the role of producer
those involved are still silent about
further information on paddington 3 but
king at least shared that with the end
of the current script
there was still plenty of room for
further sequels
either way we are excited and we look
forward to hearing more news about
paddington 3. spider-man into the
spider-verse was packed with
nasty villains led of course by wilson
fisk aka kingpin
after part 2 has been announced for a
long time rumors about a new villain
appearing in the sequel have begun to
pile up lately
this site murphy's multiverse reports
that dr jonathan
on better known as the spot will become
one of miles morales adversaries
fans may already be familiar with a spot
from the comics or from the new
spider-man series
but it is a nice idea indeed to
introduce a new villain outside of the
animated series from the 90s
the scientist spot made the first comic
book appearance back in 1984 when he was
researching ways and means to multiply
cloak superpowers
after a change of dimension his body was
suddenly covered with
many black dots that he could enlarge or
shrink and will to use as
portals after discovering his mighty
superpower he finally decided to live as
a villain and fought the likes of
spider-man
and daredevil currently it is difficult
to tell how true the rumors about the
spot's appearance in spider-man into the
spider-verse 2
are but we will keep you up to date as
[Music]
always
[Music]
you